cette histoire locale remonte aux années
20 où lendemain de la première guerre
mondiale
l'arrivée de jeunes chinois montargis
est favorisée par le développement du
rail et le mouvement travail études
jusqu'en 1927 214 chinois vont
travailler chez hugh johnson
à l'usiné voisine de châlette sur loing
la plupart à l'atelier de fabrication de
bottes et de chaussures parmi eux dingo
ping un nom qui résonnera beaucoup plus
tard en république populaire de chine en
france les jeunes idéalistes goûte à la
liberté de pensée d'expression découvre
le marxisme pour échanger entre eux ils
se retrouvent dans le jardin public
d'urzy au cours de leur conversation
leurs idées progressistes pour changer
la chine ue et la faire évoluer vers le
monde moderne se tourne peu à peu vers
le communisme
entre le 6 et le 10 juillet 1920 un
petit groupe d'étudiants chinois s'est
réuni pour parler de l'avenir politique
de la chine à la suite de quoi on
envoyait ils ont envoyé une lettre à
mots de cet homme une lettre postée à
montargis dans laquelle on lui proposait
de créer un parti politique qui va
devenir le parti communiste chinois et
on peut donc dire que le parti
communiste chinois a été créée ici dans
ce parc peut-être même sur ce banc
pourquoi pas a montargis de cette
histoire il n'en reste que des vestiges
à travers la ville un parcours
commémoratif revient sur les traces de
ce passé chinois